Naked and Afraid is a show on Discovery
Channel where they literally leave
people to survive Naked and Afraid let's
check it out
oh I just cut my thumb open pretty good
that's one of the the wounds that you
don't want to get on your opposable
thumb a very useful tool in nature in
this jungle teeming with bacteria Gary's
open wound could easily get infected oh
Atomic he didn't just put it in his
mouth a lot of people think you need
hydrogen peroxide or alcohol or
something to clean wounds you really
don't you just need some clean water
maybe some mild soap to irrigate it and
getting an infection in the hand is so
dangerous because it can lead to an
osteomyelitis which is a bone infection
or even a septic arthritis which is a
joint infection those require
hospitalization and IV antibiotics not
just oral it's a pretty good gash and
it's the only thing I know that could
work out here for something like that is
the soldier ant that has a big head on
it and some Jaws because what they'll do
is if they clamp down
they won't let go if I could find some
of those I could clamp down on there and
use them like sutures this is like one
of those things that sounds good in
survival textbooks but I can't imagine
practically this is gonna work
[Music]
this guy's performing a science
experiment on his food ripped the body
off
[Music]
oh that worked I think you're probably
better off getting some kind of clean
leaf or something and putting pressure
on it and wrapping it rather than you
are putting ants and infecting the wound
further damn it are you okay I got bit
by something
yeah this does not look good to him that
looks like some kind of venomous bite
the typical black pit right in the
center of the butt makes me think that
it's a violence Potter usually we say
recolluce spiders like that um have such
small teeth that they can't even really
penetrate that deep to really truly give
you their poison but it does enter like
the first layer of your skin which can
cause a localized irritation it hurt
when I first bit me but everything seems
to be okay there you go look at that
science is science and science
my sunburn looks really disgusting right
now
Leanne's newly formed fluid-filled
blisters provide an extra layer of
protection between damaged skin and the
Sun but if these blisters rupture they
can expose the body to infection and
they can expose the body's vulnerable
skin to even more sun damage sunburn
hurts more than bug bites oh God that's
such bad Burns and my ankles are like
super swollen oh my God yeah so bug
bites there's ankle edema petal edema oh
my God the skin tissue looks terrible
can you take much more like this yeah I
think you're gonna have to pull her out
sunburn on that side is honestly it's
like it's going through the dermal layer
it looks like almost reaching adipose
tissue and it's going to speed up her
dehydration as well I got a big
infection on that back oh that is a big
infection on his back I pretty much have
no doubt that is that is a true
cellulitis and there could be an abscess
in there as well
of it it's dead tissue
determines that there is no larva
growing under Gary's skin but the area
is severely infected what happens is
when you get an infection sometimes your
body actually builds up a wall of
protection around the infection but
that's actually problematic as that
abscess can continue to grow because of
the infection getting worse while it's
not causing a problem at the moment
anytime it would burst it would cause a
severe problem and taking antibiotics
doesn't even really solve the problem of
an abscess the treatment for an abscess
is incision and drainage of said abscess
[Music]
I can't believe they're doing this on
the show my God
this is your holy crap that's fish bait
wow this guy's chill for someone she's
got a piece their back cut off
someone's gonna slip and fall hold on
drop it if you have to no it can't get
wet
sorry
oh
[Music]
what's the one with the metal plate in
her clavicle
[Music]
oh that's really bad the clavicle is
supposed to go from the breastbone here
to the acromion which is at the top of
the shoulder and hers is like going up
here like much further away from the
intended point of their chromium and one
of the biggest dangers to this is that
that loose bone can actually puncture
the lung and cause your lung to collapse
yo
oh my goodness what is that it's a huge
banana tree are those unripe bananas so
green I don't think those are gonna be
edible unripened bananas are edible they
just have higher starch content lower
simple sugar content also less
antioxidants I'm gonna roast some of
these bananas and see if I can make them
out of them these don't look like
bananas to me we will still be able to
eat it I mash them together some snail
and I ate a little water
that's not bad well it's good I love
that they convinced themselves
that's a decency to throw up a little
further away from the sleeping area oh
looks like those patties were no bueno
[Music]
all right my guy you need a medic stat
she's probably hypotensive
looks like a piece of his pointer finger
just got completely chopped off she's
quite deep I can actually see your bone
there wow there's a possibility that
you've actually cut a vein yeah again
hand very dangerous area to develop all
those infections we talked about earlier
and the fact that he's losing so much
blood in the wild I mean that's
essentially uh a dead sentence
[Music]
whoa look at this this is edible
I have all this oh that man it's so
scary unless you're like a mushroom
expert to know which mushrooms are
edible which ones are not uh which ones
you have to heat up to destroy the
toxins inside of them because some of
them have toxins that are really bad and
he usually denatures them but man it's
hard to know which ones are safe
[Music]
is admitted into the hospital I hope
that he walks in with the outfit and
everything I just gotta update from the
nurse that Dave's condition definitely
declined some he's starting to get some
GI issues as far as like nausea vomiting
diarrhea basically sounds like his body
is violently trying to expel something
that it doesn't like
experts identified the mushrooms Dave
consumed as Fried Chicken mushrooms
which should not be eaten raw wow don't
eat fried chicken mushrooms raw
this morning my legs were completely
covered in red dots it looked like some
kind of
deadly this contagious disease it was
awful what I don't understand is on
shows like this when they sleep outdoors
and they get this terrible rash how are
they certain that this rash is caused by
bug bites allergic contaminants some
kind of viral illness because you're
exposed to so much and the way we make
these diagnosis in our hospitals in our
offices is by getting a thorough history
but if your history is like yeah I was
sleeping in a bunch of ants eating a
bunch of questionable Foods potentially
exposed to poison ivy like how do you
make a diagnosis then Laura and Glenn
have been besieged by sand flies also as
cheaters less than 1 8 of an inch
they're the smallest of all biting and
stinging insects it is the worst itching
I've ever experienced and it's all over
my body these bites are not usually
super terrible I mean sometimes they can
carry a parasite that can lead to less
uh maniasis but that's not usually
life-threatening but I can tell that
it's really annoying my body has decided
it's just too much and I'm finally
having a reaction I go into anaphylactic
shock and be dead within minutes I don't
know that it's clear that she's having
an anaphylactic attack you definitely
want to check for that and see if that
she has oral swelling a drop in blood
pressure but she could be just having a
massive amount of histamine produced
across her skin leading to a lot of
swelling leading to lower blood pressure
leading to her feeling uncomfortable I
don't know if I would classify that as
anaphylactic shock
what happened he broke his toe
oh that's a cut toe is actually spread
um it's spread a little bit more the way
that we monitor spread here is we
usually use a marker when a patient
first comes in we'll start a treatment
and we see that the redness or the
irritation is moving away from the
margins if it's starting to spread past
them that means we haven't potentially
chosen the right antibiotics so it
appears appears that Matt has acquired
signs and symptoms of cellulitis in his
foot this superficial skin infection on
the foot again is very dangerous because
of the many small bones of the foot that
can lead to osteomyelitis again
requiring hospitalization IV antibiotics
extremely painful unable to ambulate in
the survival situation it's kind of a
no-go a little stick okay okay
just made an incision and she's joining
the past out of it oh she thinks it's
abscess I think that just like evacuate
him and give him antibiotics
I'm tripping out over here
panic attack
weird firing enclosed space what's
happening
dehydration
can you look at me I can't catch my
breath
is he having a heart attack
all right so very high blood pressure
unclear why I mean he's a stressful
State It's a combination of each talk
and dehydration I recommendations
I mean at least for now spill water all
over his body allow himself to cool down
because remember when you put water on a
hot body and it evaporates that actually
cools The Superficial skin surface
you've heard of street magic but have
you heard of Street medicine AKA
curbside consult check out my last
episode and leave a comment where you
think I should go next as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]